madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues les
français ont décidé en élisant leur
député à l'assemblée nationale de priver
le président de la république de
majorité absolue notre assemblée
aujourd'hui à l'image de notre pays
fracturé avoir voulu dissoudre des
clivages politiques par des débauchages
individuels
north a consisté au final qu'à remettre
au goût du jour la vieille recette de la
petite soupe sur le petit réchaud
dénoncé en son temps par le général de
gaulle mais n'aura pas permis de relever
le défi essentiel enrayer le déclin de
la france cette petite soupe nous n'en
voulons pas notre responsabilité claire
ni compromission ni petits arrangements
avec un président de la république dont
nous contestons les orientations
chancelante depuis 2010 est sur la dette
sur l'énergie sur la souveraineté
agricoles et industriels sur la sécurité
sur l'immigration sur la transition
écologique mais jamais de blocage
stérile nous n'avons pas l'intention de
tous paralysés alors que notre pays a
déjà pris 30 ans de retard faute d'une
vision claire et d'une action résolue
nous ferons tout pour que les cinq
prochaines années soit plus utile à
notre nation que l'ont été les 10
dernières nous avons pour boussole le
bien commun de la france et des français
dès qu il en sera question nous serons
au rendez vous oui nous sommes prêts à
voter tous les textes qui est rond dans
le sens du sursaut national celui du
pouvoir d'achat par le travail de la
reconstruction de notre appareil
industriel de la sanction des
délinquants ou de l'accès à la santé
mais pour que la france retrouve la
maîtrise de son destin nous vous
engageons madame la première ministre à
une franche rupture avec la politique du
chien crevé au fil de l'eau il est temps
de répondre à l' attente légitime
d'autorité dans notre pays d'autorité du
savoir et de l'enseignant à l'école
d'autorité des policiers dans nos
quartiers d'autorité de la loi et de la
sanction vis-à-vis des délinquants
d'autorité de nos frontières face à des
flux migratoires qui déborde nos
capacités d'assimilation
l'humiliation qu'a représenté pour les
français la chienlit du stade de france
est un énième symptômes de l'alarmante
déliquescence de l'autorité dans notre
pays nous vous appelons en prendre la
mesure et à prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent
si vous êtes disposé à construire assez
de places de prison nettement plus que
les 2000 places supplémentaires de la
dernière mandature vous pouvez compter
sur nous si vous êtes disposé instaurer
des peines minimales exemplaire pour
enfin sanctionné les délinquants vous
pouvez compter sur nous si vous êtes
disposé à plafonner strictement
l'immigration en fonction de nos
capacités d'amis d'assimilation vous
pouvez compter sur nous si vous êtes
disposé à expulser les étrangers fiché
pour radicalisation terroristes vous
pouvez compter sur nous
nous devons surtout aussi et peut-être
surtout répondre à cette exigence de
justice sociale la plus élémentaire
pouvoir vivre dignement de son travail
un coût de chaque à crédit de dépenses
sociales incontrôlée vous avez fait
croire que l'assistanat était la
solution alors qu'il n'est qu'illusion
plutôt que de multiplier les chèques
d'argent public tâchant de réduire
l'écart délieront entre le salaire brut
et le salaire net en réduisant les
prélèvements obligatoires dont nous
sommes les champions
plutôt que de réduire les retraites
fruit d'une vie de travail par leur sous
valorisation ou la hausse de la csg et y
est enfin de courage de mener une
réforme juste de notre système de
retraite oui nous devons tout faire pour
revaloriser le travail et il n'y a pas
de droit son devoir si vous êtes prêts à
exiger des bénéficiaires du rsa 15
heures d'activité par exemple dans nos
ehpad qui manque ne serait ce que deux
présences humaines auprès de nos aînés
alors vous pouvez compter sur nous ne
nous dupont pas la clé du pouvoir
d'achat est là que la france produisent
plus d'emplois et plus de richesses
alors ne tuons pas ceux qui restent
d'industrie d'industrie au nom d'un
écologisme punitif dont le seul effet
est de produire plus à l'étranger ce que
nous ne produisons plus en france
nos importations représentent désormais
la majorité de notre empreinte carbone
nous tuons à la fois nos emplois et
notre planète pour créer les conditions
d'une réindustrialisation carbonée il
faut moins de normes moins de paperasse
et une vraie politique de filières et il
nous faut surtout et il nous faut
surtout madame le premier ministre
retrouver l'excellence nucléaire sans
laquelle l'électricité sera plus chère
et plus dé carbonée que de temps perdu
renationaliser edf pourquoi pas si ça
n'est pas pour mieux le démembrer
nationaliser les pertes pour privatiser
les profits ça ne peut pas être ça le
projet
enfin arrêtons arrêtons d'être les
idiots du village planétaire toutes les
nations défendre leurs intérêts y
compris au sein de l'union européenne
personne ne défendra les nôtres à notre
place et nous devons enfin sortir de
l'illusion de l'argent magique qui
menace notre souveraineté la réalité se
rappelle déjà à nous au terme d'un
mandat qui a augmenté de 700 milliards
la dette publique deux fois plus qu'en
allemagne est nettement moins en raison
de la crise sanitaire qu'en raison de
vos choix budgétaires comme l'a rappelé
la cour des comptes
nous voilà nous voilà aujourd'hui au
pied du mur avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt alors revenons au bon sens de
montesquieu la politique fondamentale le
point fondamental de la bonne
administration est simple il ne consiste
qu'à ajuster la dépense avec la recette
tous les entrepreneurs doivent le faire
toutes les familles doivent le faire
votre gouvernement doit aussi le faire
madame la première ministre est là
dessus votre discours ne nous laisse
interrogatif
les familles et les entreprises
françaises sont toujours aussi accablé
d'impôts et de taxes le taux des
prélèvements obligatoires est le même en
2021 qu'il était en 2016 alors que notre
hôpital est au bord de l'implosion que
le niveau de notre éducation s'effondre
et qu'elle ne prend même plus assez le
mérite que la justice ne sanctionne trop
peu et trop lentement et qe 2 millions
de français sont privés d'accès à la
santé c'est l'argent du contribuable
trop souvent gaspillée la réalité est là
il est possible et nécessaire de faire
mieux avec moins d'argent public soyons
clair augmenter les effectifs de
soignants ou de magistrats oui mais à
condition par ailleurs de réduire
drastiquement les emplois publics dans
les administrations centrales d'en finir
avec cette bureaucratie tatillonne quand
les quelques 1200 agences de l'état dans
tous ses bureaux qui ont pullulé à
mesure que les services de terrain se
raréfiaient la méthode de la révision
générale des politiques publiques d'il
ya 15 ans n'était peut-être pas la bonne
mais cela ne justice il ne justifie en
rien de laisser filer le nombre
d'emplois publics comme vous le faites
depuis 2010 cette soixante dix mille
emplois supplémentaires dans la seule
faction public faire des économies
d'argent public est possible comme nous
le démontrons dans les régions dont nous
avons la charge
et il faudra et il faudra enfin avoir le
courage de protéger l'argent des
français tout autant contre la fraude
sociale que contre les champions de
l'optimisation fiscale qui abusent sous
vos yeux sous les yeux de bercy de prix
de transfert pour ne pas payer d'impôts
en france nous serons à vos côtés si
vous avez le courage de réduire la
dépense publique est efficace pour
réduire l'imposition confiscatoire du
travail y compris madame le premier
ministre l'imposition des moyens d'aller
au travail c'est à dire des carburants
la taxation des carburants c'est le plus
injuste des impôts parce que c'est
l'impôt qui visent directement et
exclusivement cette france qui se lève
tôt pour bosser qui ne s'en sort plus
cette politique du courage que nous
appelons de nos voeux et la seule apte à
rétablir la cohésion nationale au tour
au terme de ces cinq années notre nation
est épuisée fracturée les français ont
envoyé un message au président de la
république l'arrogance solitaire et le
mépris des corps intermédiaires doit
cesser au cours des cinq prochaines
années l'assemblée des élus de la nation
que nous sommes que nous sommes tous
devraient atteindre devrait être entendu
et nous les députés républicains nous
avons un combat celui de la cohésion
nationale la cohésion nationale ce n'est
pas un slogan tiède et vaporeux comme
l'est devenu le vivre ensemble c'est un
inlassable combat animé par l'amour de
la france qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il n'y
ait pas une france des précaires une
france des protégés mais une seule
france qu'il n'y ait pas une france des
jeunes et une france des seniors mais
une seule france qu'il n'y ait pas une
franche des métropoles une france des
villages mais une seule france qui n'est
pas une france des usines une frange de
start up mais une seule france qu'il n'y
ait pas une france qui croient au ciel
une france qui n'y croit pas mais une
seule france la france fière de son
histoire est sûr de son destin notre
nation n'est ni un coran d'individu
n'est juste à position de communauté
elle est ce que nous avons en héritage
en partage elle nous dépasse nous oblige
non seulement nous avons le droit mais
nous avons le devoir de défendre notre
nation et notre mode de vie oui nous
voulons que la france reste la france
que notre nation on retrouve son rang
voilà le chemin exigeant sur lequel vous
savez pouvoir nous trouver
[Applaudissements]